a question I get asked all the time is
Lucca how can they speak better and more
confidently and faster and the simple
reply is in order to speak well you have
to speak you have to get into the habit
of speaking your record and there are
many ways in many circumstances many
people you can talk to but one very
efficient thing that you can do and you
can do it directly at your place if you
have an internet connection and a nice
computer is simply to have a language
exchange so what I'm going to do now is
I'm going to show you a few but
extremely important that efficient
things to keep in mind to have a
fantastic plan to change and remember
there's always a final super cool tip at
the end of the video so stay here until
the end if you want to create a great
sustainable efficient routine for
language exchange the first step that
you have to do is make decisions take a
piece of paper and write down why you
want to do this it has to be clear to
you and when put a starting date and
tell yourself from this moment on I'm
going to start taking language exchanges
every single week maybe you find
yourself in some parts of the world
where meeting people and talking to them
face-to-face is kind of problematic
especially if you're looking for farmers
or maybe you do live in a cosmopolitan
city where there's a chance of meeting a
lot of people but you simply don't want
to and you want to be at the comfort of
your own place and talk through Skype or
through the Internet in general so the
next thing you want to do is to find
platforms where you can find native
speakers to talk to and as usual on the
internet offers a deluge a wealth of
possibilities but here's the thing the
problem is that there are so many
platforms that offer the service that
it's difficult to choose a good one so
make sure that you invest the time and
find one good platform that you like it
be it because it's user friendly it
because you like it visually the
important thing is you find just one and
they use of that and possibly I move on
to another one oh and by the way in the
description box you will find a list of
platforms that have used or that I
highly recommend so now you have
compelling reasons a date of reference
and then on top of that you found your
favorite platform what is the next step
so the next step is to build a very cool
profile because that's what people are
going to take a look at and based on
that they're going to make a decision
whether they want to have a language
exchange with you or not a good profile
has to be compelling short simple
possibly in two or three other languages
remember it's really important so having
a good profile is fantastic but it's not
enough people might contact you or
people might not convert you so if
people don't contact you which is
possible you have to contact them and in
that regard you have to send a very cool
message I don't know if it has ever
happened to you that you were trying to
contact as many people as possible on
other platforms maybe and you created
the same stock message that you send to
everybody so in that regard don't make
that mistake what you should do is to
look into other people's profiles to
look for one or two details and then use
that as a hook because that gives the
impression that you have actually read
the profile that you got interested in
that profile instead of sending the same
message to everyone remember the profile
building your own profile is important
but also sending people a compelling
message a personal message is really
important to get into a cool connection
so imagine that you send the school
message the person replied and you're
finally going to have your language of
change now what do you want to do is
don't focus too much on the language but
focus on communication focus on
interaction focus on cooperation that's
what counts the most the first
impression is always the strongest and
the most important so it's not about the
quantity of words the cool expressions
that you use the fact that you're using
the language but focus on speaking
smiling interacting asking being curious
when the person talks listen attentively
that creates a very positive environment
and that is going to work wonders for
your language learning skills and his or
her language learning skills
whatever happens always make sure that
you record the conversation this is
really important and it's easy to do
nowadays you can use a mobile phone
maybe your iPad your computer so whether
you have a conversation on the Internet
through Skype or other software programs
or you have an in real life always make
sure if they have a recording device
with you remember recording the
information is really important because
later you can take a look at it you can
take a listen or again you can even see
it if you're recording video and that
will be really useful to further
memorize the information that is being
processed there so here you have it with
these six simple tips just get into a
language of change just jump into it
don't think about it too much and you
will see what an enormous difference it
can make it can be free it can be
efficient if you find the right language
partner you can do it on a weekly basis
maybe a couple of times a week and if
you do it well and you find this good
environment good positive environment of
cooperation of stimulation of
inspiration you will be able to do this
for a long time and it will work wonders
for your language
skills it will prepare you for real
conversations in real life as always I
have written an extensive article about
it and I read it out loud and I have
extra tips tax for video demonstrations
on the blog so please click on the link
in the description box head over the
blog and let's have a very constructive
in cooperation to build our language
skills in any language so as usual I
have one question and one cool tip so
the question goes like this have you
ever had a language exchange and what
are your best strategies when it comes
to communicating interacting for example
through Skype or through another
software program how did that go what
did you learn and faders and end
victories please share only the stories
in the comment section below I will be
more than happy to reply and hopefully
we can have a constructive conversation
we can learn from one another so time
for one final extra tip so always make
sure that when you talk when you get
your point across whatever you're
talking about the person who's listening
to you takes notes and writes down and
provides the feedback at the end of your
language exchange in this way you can
then take a look you can listen to the
recording and you can take a look at the
feedback that was given to you that was
that is written that you can actually
see and you can learn from it so always
make sure that you go back to what you
did for the sake of learning because
when you take a look at it again without
having to speak because you're just
listening to the recording you're
attacking the piece of information from
another angle you're not stressed you
can just focus on learning and
extracting the information that was
given to you while you were talking this
always makes a huge difference and if
you can maybe reduce the amount of
language exchanges that you do twice a
week but always make sure that you
absorb the information later by
listening 48 hours after each language
exchange
[Music]
[Music]